okay welcome back everybody okay so
today we're going to go a little bit
deeper into linear differential
equations just to review of what we did
last time so we went over some of the
basic kind of methods in calculus how to
do the derivative the chain rule things
like that we looked at the simplest
linear OTE X dot equals lambda X where X
is just a single scalar number okay we
started thinking a little bit about what
the exponential function really means so
e is of course Euler's number anything
that has oily name on it is really
really important and this time we're
going to start looking at more general
ways of solving these differential
equations using Taylor series so this is
going to be one of the most general
techniques in the class you can solve
almost any differential equation just by
assuming a Taylor series and plugging it
in okay so you can always find the
lecture notes online this is the
overview of topics today so like I said
we're gonna go over Taylor series and
how to solve linear systems we're going
to go into what a Taylor series actually
means and do some MATLAB examples so
plotting some Taylor series
approximation and then we're going to
start looking at second order systems
like the linear harmonic oscillator if
we have time okay okay so when I say
second order or higher order that really
means the order of the highest
derivative of our variable so X dot
equals lambda X is first order because
I'm taking one derivative X double dot
plus x equals zero is second order
because I'm taking two derivatives and
in general I could have like a tenth or
and ninth or an 11th order differential
equation if I had nine or ten or eleven
derivatives okay okay
good can everyone see the board on the
screens yeah okay good okay so we're
gonna start with Taylor series all right
just a quick show of hands how many of
you remember somewhat what Taylor series
are how many of you would like a bit of
a refresher on Taylor series okay good
so this is going to be a lecture where
we really go deep into Taylor series
we'll come back to it a couple times but
we're going to really start using it
pretty heavily in the future lectures
okay so we have our first-order linear
differential equation X dot equals ax X
is just a number it's not a vector or
anything and we know from last time that
the solution is X at time t is equal to
e to the constant a times time times my
initial condition X at time 0 okay we
got this last time and we started
thinking about what really what is this
e to the HT function mean this
exponential function so we're going to
derive this another way using the Taylor
series
okay so let's use Taylor series and what
that means is that we're going to assume
that our function X of time has a
certain functional form and then we're
going to solve for the coefficients of
that function okay so X of T we're gonna
say that this equals some constant term
plus another constant times time plus a
second constant times time squared
third constant C three times time cubed
and so on and so forth forever so I'm
gonna say plus higher order terms okay
h.o.t just means higher order terms I
could also say order delta T to the
fourth because there's terms of T to the
fourth
sorry just order T to the 4th to the 5th
to the 6th and so on and so forth ok ok
so we're going to assume that we can
write our function X like this and then
we're going to essentially take its
derivative plug it into this equation
and solve for these coefficients see how
many of you have done this before in
differential equations how many of you
have not done this before
ok so this is pretty a pretty powerful
technique sorry ok ok so let's get going
so the time derivative of X we literally
just take the time derivative of every
single one of these terms in order ok so
it's the derivative of a constant zero
ok derivative of C 1 times T just C 1
ok so C 1 plus 2 times C 2 time plus 3
times C 3 x squared plus 4 times C 4
time cubed plus dot dot dot ok good so
now we're going to multiply this term by
a and plug it into the equation I'm
gonna close the door okay so a times X
dot is just a C 1 plus 2 a C 2 T plus 3
a C 3 T squared plus 4ac for T cube plus
a bunch more terms like that
ok forever and ever and ever and now I'm
supposed to take X of T ok I did
something wrong what did I do wrong
ok I really should do a times X not a
times X dot right ok let's try this one
more time
okay a times X is just a C naught plus a
C 1 T plus a C 2 T squared plus AC
3t cubed plus dot that dot that dot that
works better okay and now I want X dot
to equal a X and I'm just going to do it
term by term okay so I'm going to take
all of the different powers of T and I'm
gonna make their coefficients match
forever up until infinity okay so the
constant term if I have the T to the
zero term I have a c1 here and that has
to equal a times C not here okay so c1
equals a times C not fine okay in the
T's terms I'm matching to c2 and that
has to equal a times c1
okay this is starting to look like a
pattern right so I have a four-year-old
son and everything as a pattern now he
thinks okay so T squared we have 3 c3
equals a times C 2 and so on so let's
just write the last one so I'm guessing
it's 4 times C 4 equals a times c3 right
good okay okay so what's the next step
in this in this progression what do we
do next
sorry is there any other information I
have about this differential equation we
know the initial conditions right so we
know that X at time 0 is just X knots
okay so I can call this you know X sub 0
if I want so if I plug in T equals 0 in
my Taylor expansion for X I get that c0
has to equal X 0 okay so this is equal
so c0 equals x 0 and that means that c1
is a times X 0 and two times c2 is a
times C 1 but c1 equals a times X 0 so I
have a squared over 2 x0 equals c2 so
everyone see how I did that all right so
I plugged in a times X 0 here I got a
squared X 0 and I divided by 2 a squared
X 0 divided by 2 okay C 3 is the same
thing I plug in this for c2 I get an a
cubed X 0 divided by 2 divided by 3 so
divided by 3 factorial C 4 is a to the
fourth X 0 divided by 4 factorial and
all the way down to C n is going to
equal a to the N X 0 over N factorial ok
and so now that we have all of these
terms in terms of the initial condition
the constant of the differential
equation a we can plug these into our
Taylor series and get an expression for
X so X of T was equal to C naught
plus c1 times T so that's X not a times
T plus c2 times T squared over 2
factorial ya plus c2 times T squared is
a squared over 2t squared times X not
plus c3 times T cubed is a cubed over 3
factorial T cubed X naught and I can
pull the X naught out of all of these
and get 1 plus 80 plus 80 squared over 2
factorial plus 80 cubed over 3 factorial
plus dot dot times X knots then that's
something up I'm sorry wait here for
example okay so the reason there's a
factorial I'm plug some yes so the
previous term c2 has a one half in it
and then I divide by another 3 so I have
a 2 times 3 in the denominator then in
this term here c3 has a 2 times 3 in the
denominator and then I divide by 4 so I
get a 4 factorial in c4 and this
right yeah so we're getting everything
in terms of X naught okay so essentially
we haven't assumed anything about the
solution except that we can write our
solution as some expansion in powers of
T and then we solve for what the
coefficients of that expansion have to
be and what we get out is the
exponential function so this is e to the
a T times X naught and in general this
is a pretty common way of doing things
so if there's a differential equation
that comes up a lot of times in physics
what I might do is plug in a Taylor
series expansion solve for the
coefficients that that expansion has to
have to satisfy the equation and if I
end up using that function all the time
I'm going to give it a name I'm gonna
say I define this function to be e to
the a T right you can think of sines and
cosines and e to the 80s and cautious as
cinches those are just special functions
that have Taylor series expansions that
come up a lot in physics okay vessels
functions Ares functions they can all be
derived from key critical differential
equations okay any questions about this
Taylor series example any at all
nope okay good so let's do a little
review on what Taylor series really mean
just get some examples so we're gonna
use Taylor series over and over and over
again and so I really want us to just be
very very comfortable with these so for
example I might in the future have a
vector of states X so I might have a
bunch of numbers that are changing in
time and they might be related by some
big matrix a and the matrix exponential
e to the matrix a times time times a
vector of initial conditions will be the
general solution of that system of
equations so most of you have probably
seen this before and the way that we
interpret this matrix exponential is by
using the Taylor series expansion of e
to the a T and plugging in matrices for
a okay so using the Taylor series is
going to be really really important so
why don't we just go into a little bit
more depth about what the Taylor series
means okay so I think the Taylor series
is probably the high point of calculus
at least the calculus series that we all
take like one two and three Taylor
series is the foundation for all of the
numerical approximations we'll do in
this class when we do numerical
integration or differentiation of data
when we take a differential equation and
try to integrate a trajectory through it
for example if we're going to predict
where a spacecraft or a satellite is
going to go or if a comet is going to
hit earth right we're going to have
approximations to the solution of that
equation and the quality of our
approximation is going to depend on the
Taylor series terms okay
so the Taylor series okay a function can
be expanded in a Taylor series if it's
sufficiently smooth so smooth means it
doesn't have you know terrible kinks or
discontinuities it means what we think
it means by smooth so a function f of X
plus a delta X can be Taylor expanded at
a point X and this is if X if f is
sufficiently smooth at X so there's a
bunch of conditions that I'm going to
kind of gloss over most of the functions
we care about how to Taylor series
expansions and we write it like this
so f of X plus Delta X is equal to f of
X plus DF DX evaluated at my base point
x times Delta X plus d squared F DX
squared the second derivative of my
function evaluated at x times Delta x
squared plus I can just keep going all
day long
DX cubed evaluated at x times Delta X
cubed plus dot dot plus the nth
derivative of F with respect to X at X
Delta X to the n plus Delta okay it goes
on forever and ever and ever
okay so there's two key parts of this
Taylor series expansion what are the two
the two key parts of this what are the
two variables here X and Delta X okay so
the way I think about this is I have
some function f of a variable X I pretty
much always draw the same function don't
know why I always have
and the idea is if I know my function f
at some base point X and I also know its
derivative and maybe it's pervert
and its third and fourth and fifth and
higher-order derivatives then I can get
a really good approximation for this
function in some neighborhood around X
some X plus or minus Delta X okay so for
example if I just know the first
derivative DF DX evaluated at X I know
the slope of this line then I can
approximate f of X plus Delta X by just
taking f of X and adding where that line
would take me okay that's my first order
Taylor series expansion a second-order
Taylor series expansion will bring me
down on this parabola and get me much
much closer to the solution okay so this
is an extremely useful form for
approximating smooth functions in a
neighborhood of a point if I know
something about the smoothness at that
point smoothness just means that the
derivatives exist okay you'll hear me
say that a lot okay questions about the
Taylor series expansion yeah
so when you go to like an in street
representation of extreme function how
do you define the smoothness so I guess
you would assume that the function that
that discrete representation was derived
from is smooth and has derivatives so
for example if I want to solve a fluids
equation with the navier's stokes
equation I'm going to do it on a
discrete domain of you know a bunch of
gridded points and grid it in time but
my equations the navier stokes equations
are twice continuously differentiable in
space and once continuously
differentiable in time
so I just know that my solution has to
have that amount of smoothness okay so I
have to have first and second
derivatives in X okay so I'm gonna write
this just another way because I really
want us I want us to be able to use the
Taylor series very very naturally so
we'll do another quick example or rather
another representation and then we'll do
a MATLAB example okay so another way we
can write this is let's say we have a
function f of X expanded about a base
point called a so in the board on the
left our base point is X and we assume
that Delta X is a small distance from X
so another way to say this is that f of
X is going to be expanded about some
point a and I can say well f of X is
going to equal F of a plus DF DX at a
times X minus a now I hope this is small
right this is like my Delta X this is
playing the same role as Delta X plus d
squared F DX squared at a X minus a
squared plus so on and so forth this is
just another way of writing it if I
don't want to use X's
Dell taxes and you can convince yourself
that this is exactly the same as what I
wrote on the left board if you let X
minus a equal Delta X okay so let's do
an example in MATLAB okay so we're going
to do our first example how many of you
really know like the Taylor series of
most functions by heart like if I asked
you what the Taylor series of sine of X
is how many it could just tell me right
now
No okay this is this is gonna be super
important stuff this is one of those
things you should know really really
important okay so and I'll tell you why
it's important in a little bit okay so
our first example is going to be f of X
equals sine of X okay so how do i okay
we're going to do f of X equals sine of
X and we're going to expand about a
point a equals zero so this has a
special name this is called a Maclaurin
series okay and so we can essentially
just apply this formula we know that
sine is SuperDuper smooth right I can
take the derivative of sine all day long
and I get nice clean functions that can
be evaluated on the whole number line so
we're going to just do this exact same
procedure okay so this is equal to f of
zero what's F f is just sine so it's
equal to sine of zero that's this term
plus the derivative of sine at zero
what's the derivative of sine cosine so
cosine of zero times X plus okay what's
the second derivative of sine minus sign
right derivative of coast is minus sine
minus sine is zero times x squared over
two factorial
did I mess up feel like there supposed
to be some factorials here okay
you guys need to catch me on this if i
if i miss factorials
the whole whole framework collapses okay
so all of these terms have a really
important factorial term that keeps this
series convergent for most functions
super important to have these factorials
1 over 2 factorial 1 over 3 factorial
and so on and so forth ok okay the third
term is the third derivative of f with
respect to X so what's the derivative of
minus sine minus cosine minus cos of 0 X
cubed over 3 factorial plus sine of 0 X
to the fourth over 4 factorial minus now
plus cos 0 X to the fifth over 5
factorial and we can just keep going
because there's a pattern okay so the
sine of 0 is always 0 coasts of 0 is
always 1 and so all of the terms with
sine 0 go away and I'm only left with
the coasts 0 terms so I have X plus X
cubed over 3 factorial sorry minus X
cubed plus good I'm keeping everyone
awake today because I have not had my
coffee plus X to the fifth over 5
factorial what do you think the next
term is going to be minus X to the
seventh over 7 factorial plus that I
thought and we can just go on and on
forever and ever
okay so this is the Taylor series
expansion of sine of X it's kind of
funny right we can write sine of X in
terms of a bunch of odd polynomials but
you need all of them ok any idea what's
coasts what f of X equals coasts x
equals
it's all of the even terms that we
forgot so this is kind of an exercise
you can do this should be one
I think - x squared over two factorial
plus X to the fourth over 4 factorial
minus X to the sixth over 6 factorial
and I thought that that done ok
questions about about the Taylor series
on these specific examples all right all
we needed to know was F and its
derivatives all of its derivatives at
the point x equals 0 and we can get this
entire Taylor series expansion ok who
would like to see this actually coded up
in MATLAB to see kind of how good the
approximation really is okay let's try
it ok so you can find the matlab code
online it's also in the notes so let's
try this ok good ok so first things
first we're just going to plot our sine
wave so I clear all close all and CLC I
think that means it clears the command
window so I'm going to create a vector X
from minus 10 and increments of 0.01 to
10 okay this is a big vector for minus
10 to 10 in increments of 0.01 about
2,000 points okay and the first thing
I'm going to do is just plot my sine
function ok so I'm going to plot X by Y
in black and I want it to be big so I'm
gonna make it line with two let's call
this test Taylor
okay there's my sine-wave okay so now
we're gonna try our different Taylor
series approximations to this okay I'm
gonna make an axis which goes for a
minus 10 to 10 and X and minus 10 to 10
and Y and I'm going to turn a grid on
and I'm gonna hold on so hold on allows
me to plot other things on top of this
so I'm going to go a little bit fast on
the MATLAB I'm going to assume most of
you have seen some MATLAB before but I
really want to build up your ability to
make nice figures in MATLAB okay okay so
now what we're going to do is plot the
first order Taylor series approximation
first order Taylor expansion okay so how
many of you have seen the poly vowel and
polyfit commands only a few of you how
many haven't it's okay if you haven't
okay
so Paul eval and polyfit is just a
really really nice cute little MATLAB
code that allows you to define the
coefficients of a polynomial and then
evaluate that polynomial on a vector of
X values okay so that's what I'm just
going to use for shorthand if you want
to know more about it you can type doc
pol eval or doc Polly fit and you can
get the whole documentation of what it's
doing we're actually gonna write our own
Paul eval and Polly fit in a couple of
weeks okay so our first order Taylor
series approximation was just X so it's
a polynomial with leading coefficient
one and constant coefficient zero so
this is just X plus zero okay that's the
coefficients of my X polynomial and I'm
gonna say that my Taylor series of first
order is equal to Paul eval I'm going to
evaluate my polynomial P at my vector X
okay so I've defined a polynomial P it's
just X and I'm going to evaluate that
polynomial at my grid of data points
negative 10 to 10
and now I can plot X by my first order
Taylor series expansion in blue in a
smaller line width okay that's my first
order Taylor series approximation kind
of cool right and so you notice that in
a vicinity of the origin x equals zero
it's actually not too bad of an
approximation right it's got in fact the
error will be proportional to Delta X
cubed because those are the terms that
I'm leaving out right I'm getting all
the Delta X terms I'm leaving out all
the Delta X cubed and fists and sevenths
so if Delta X is small my error is gonna
be small okay now let's do a third order
Taylor expansion so this is on the
homework I just posted the homework this
morning I wrote it just before coming to
class and there's going to be an example
like this where you're going to kind of
compute a Taylor series and then plot it
okay so this should be easy P equals
what's our third order Taylor series
approximation minus one over three
factorial X cubed plus X okay so what is
that minus 1 over factorial 3 0 1 0
right so this is my Delta X cubed term I
have 0 Delta x squared terms and I have
1 X Delta X and then 0 constants that's
my Taylor series expansion up to order 3
and I can say that YT 3 equals poly Val
P evaluated at X so I'm going to
evaluate that new polynomial at my
points X and I'm going to plot X with my
third order Taylor series expansion
let's say in red okay and I'm just going
to keep going and going so I'm going to
do a 5th order so to do that I need to
add a minus 1 over factorial 5 I think
not - plus thank you very much and this
should be a green so I'm just gonna make
this match my script okay and finally
the seventh I'm going to have a minus 1
over factorial 7 0 YT 7 and let's make
that magenta and I should probably put a
legend up right because I've added a lot
of plots now ok so my first function is
sine of X followed by third order sorry
first order third order fifth order and
seventh order good that's how you do a
legend
okay so that's my Taylor series
approximation for increasing orders for
sine of X okay and it's kind of
interesting right I have you know I
start with the blue curve then I get my
red curve the cubic term then the green
term which is fifth order and finally
the magenta curve which is seventh order
so what we're finding is that to capture
these switchbacks in the sine function I
need higher and higher order even
polynomials but the convergence is
really terrible if I want to go five or
six periods out then I'm gonna need a
ton of polynomial orders to really
capture that okay so this is just a kind
of quick example of how to do Taylor
series how to visualize them and how to
interpret them okay any questions about
the MATLAB code or the physical
interpretation yeah okay sure so the
size of the neighborhood and depends on
the order so there's a few ways of
thinking about this if you in if you
have higher and higher and higher order
Taylor series expansions and your
function is sufficiently smooth then
your radius where your function is
accurate gets bigger and bigger that's
one way to think about it
that really only works for very smooth
functions because there could be some
point at which no Taylor series
approximation will work okay if there's
some really big discontinuity another
way of thinking about this is if I
always have a really small Delta X so
I'm always in a very small neighborhood
of x equals zero then my taylor series
expansion gets more and more and more
accurate okay so the error for this
magenta curve has ordered Delta X to the
ninth because those are the terms that
I'm leaving out are the Delta X to the
ninth terms so if Delta X is 0.1 my
error is like ten to the minus nine it's
one billionth really really small okay
that's another way of thinking about it
and if i zoom in here let's just try to
zoom in this might be a little hard to
zooming enough well they all look way
too good okay so these orders are
polynomial so I would have to actually
subtract each of these values from my
true sine X and plot the error on a log
plot to see the error decreasing for
higher order okay
that's something you can do right you
can take the black curve and subtract
all of these approximations from it and
then plot the log of the absolute value
to see the error in log space okay good
okay what do you see in the back on the
screens do you see the board or me yeah
okay good okay so a final example just
to really drive this home so I'm gonna
pull you a lot this class just to figure
out what you do and don't know complex
analysis how many have some experience
with complex functions like if I wanted
to plug complex numbers into sine of X
or e to the i-x how many have not seen
this or would like a big refresher
okay good a little bit more than half of
you okay so Taylor series are also
really really nice because they
generalize to complex valued functions
really really well okay so one of the
examples that's going to be super
important we're gonna find C we're gonna
find examples of functions where we need
complex valued solutions so differential
equations that have complex valued
solutions so I want us to get pretty
comfortable with complex numbers
and so in particular we're gonna start
by saying what is e well first of all
what's the Taylor series for e to the X
we just wrote this down it's 1 plus x
plus
x squared over two factorial X cubed
over three factorial X fourth over 4
factorial X fifth over 5 factorial this
is one of the functions that have
actually worth knowing by heart it's so
powerful and versatile you're going to
use e to the X is the basis for the
solution to all linear differential
equations every single one of them that
you can possibly write down the solution
is related to e to the X higher order
systems of equations harmonic oscillator
equations it's worth remembering this
function okay now what if I plug in e to
the complex number I times X okay
remember I just equals the square root
of negative 1 ok someone was clever one
day and started taking the square roots
of all of the numbers and realized that
when they tried to take the square root
of negative 1 there was no number that
one squared equals negative 1 so they
invented the number I so that when you
square it it's negative 1 and algebra
was born so if I take e to the i-x how
do I evaluate this complex valued
function now ok
sounds like you remember the the answer
I could plug in IX every time I see an X
here very generic way of doing things
the Taylor series is one of the most
generic ways of representing a function
so this is equal to 1 plus IX plus I x
squared over 2 factorial plus IX cubed
over 3 factorial I X to the fourth to
the fourth over 4 factorial plus I don't
really need to keep writing this top
tapped up okay
and what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to expand all of these powers of I
times X so I'm going to get 1 plus IX
plus what's I squared minus 1 so that's
minus x squared over 2 factorial what's
I squared times I just minus I so minus
I times X cubed over 3 factorial
now I to the fourth is I squared squared
it's minus 1 squared is plus 1 and now
we started all over again so now we have
a plus I X to the fifth over 5 factorial
and so on and so forth okay now if we
really want to we should represent this
as a real part plus and imaginary parts
and so I'm going to collect all of the
things that don't have I which happen to
be these even powers X to the 0 X to X
to the 4th X to the sixth right that's
looking familiar and I'm going to
collect all of the odd terms that have
an eye and I'm going to write this as
okay 1 minus x squared over 2 factorial
that's my cosine cosine of X plus I
times sine of X okay so e to the i-x is
equal to cosine of X plus I times sine
of X again this is called Euler's
formula and what did I say about things
that are named after Euler super
important okay this is one of the most
important equations in all of
mathematical physics really simple just
says that I can take my exponential
function and I can write I can I can
solve that exponential function for
complex variables e to the i-x and I get
cosine of X plus I times sine of X ok
any questions about complex numbers or
Euler's formula I mean if this is new
like having questions is totally fine
even if it's not new it's totally fine
okay
just make sense yeah okay okay so the
next thing we're going to do I'm just
going to get this started in this
lecture and we're gonna continue it in
the next lecture is we're going to start
thinking about more general differential
equations so so far we've been dealing
with the simplest simplest equations we
can think of which are just X dot equals
a times X or lambda times X linear
first-order equations and very quickly
in the next two lectures we're going to
generalize this to all linear
differential equations with higher order
derivatives okay so we're gonna look now
at second-order ode E's and these are
going to look like X double dot plus x
equals zero for example okay I could
write other expressions that have you
know I could write X double dot plus X
dot plus x equals zero so what's the
defining characteristic of a
second-order ode ee has the second
derivative it doesn't have any third or
fourth or fifth derivatives but it
definitely has to have a second
derivative that it's the second-order
system okay so what's a really good
example of a second-order ode ee it's
like the equation we keep coming back to
you over and over again in physics
spring and mass a spring in the mass
right
okay so I have some mass m and I have a
spring K and I have some displacement
that is the displacement from rest X
okay so assume that if I just let my
spring you know equilibrate so this
thing's not moving and there's no forces
that's zero and X is any displacement in
addition to that rest displacement so if
I take my mass and I pull it some amount
X and I let it go what's going to happen
it's going to awfully right it's gonna
go back and forth so this is nice
because we have some physical intuition
for what the system is going to do and
we can write down the equations really
really easily so Newton's second says F
equals MA okay so what's the force on
this mass okay something like K minus KX
ya say minus KX so it pulls it back if X
is positive and if X is negative it also
pulls it back okay so minus K times X
equals mass times X double dot right
acceleration is just the second
derivative of position with respect to
time and so we get our equation X double
dot equals minus K over M X this is our
second order harmonic oscillator okay so
we're going to start solving systems
like this we're also going to go to
generic higher order systems like you
know X triple dot plus two X double dot
plus X equal zero things like that well
maybe I have a fifth or a sixth
derivative so we're going to go up to
arbitrarily high order differential
equations in the next two lectures and
we're going to use complex valued
exponential functions to do it
sorry so we're gonna use e to the lambda
so here's what I want you to do I didn't
get quite as far as I wanted to today so
there's three methods of solving the
system and I want you to explore each of
them before next lecture or at least the
first two so method one is guess a
solution right we just discussed if I
pull this mass off of equilibrium and
let it go it oscillates back and forth
so pick a function that you know
oscillates and try to solve this
differential equation method two is also
to guess but now instead of just
guessing a solution let's try each of
the lambda t let's try some solution e
to the lambda T and let's plug it into
this equation and solve for what lambda
has to be okay you're gonna find out
that you get a complex valued
exponential that's going to give you
cosines and sines okay so that's what
we're gonna do next lecture and then
we're going to generalize to higher
order ordinary differential equations
and at that point we're going to go into
systems of multivariate ordinary
differential equations
okay so homework one is posted online
you can find it on the course website
there's now a link to the course website
on the canvas page where the videos are
recorded so you can find hopefully
everything pretty easily the first
homework is due this Friday at 4 o'clock
you can email it to me in the TAS or you
can hand it in in class this shouldn't
be a very long assignment okay this is
mostly review okay I'll see you all on
Wednesday
you